bienvenue à toutes et à tous dans cette
nouvelle vidéo théorie avec les gardiens
de la galaxie volume 3 nous avons
désormais du contenu et nous avons
également eu l'intégration de nouveaux
personnages notamment un qui m'intrigue
beaucoup effectivement je vous avais
prévenu dans la vidéo précédente mais
j'ai trop envie de vous parler d'Adam
Warlock c'est vraiment l'un de mes héros
préférés de l'univers Marvel et je vais
pas vous mentir que je mise beaucoup sur
le personnage pour le futur du MCU dans
le sens où c'est un petit peu une source
de hype pour moi en réalité ce qui me
hype chez Adam c'est qu'il est un
personnage très singulier de l'univers
Marvel cette thématique forte
s'éloignent pas mal de ce que nous avons
l'habitude de voir chez les autres héros
de comics et Marvel studio devra
obligatoirement adapter certains
éléments pour le futur c'est un
raisonnement que j'aime bien avoir quand
je vous propose mes théories mais en
gros j'essaye de me mettre à la place
des scénaristes qui ont pour mission
les comics pour le grand écran et pour
cela il faut reprendre les événements
marquants et les thématiques fortes de
la vie d'un personnage puis réfléchir à
ce qui correspondrait le mieux pour
l'avancement actuel du MCU où son futur
rentrons dans le vif du sujet pour mieux
comprendre si l'on compare le Adam
Warlock du MCU fraîchement apparu grâce
au film des gardiens de la galaxie avec
celui des comics le Adam Warlock
d'origine la source de l'adaptation nous
avons le cocon dans le deuxième film des
gardiens et donc la naissance de notre
personnage check Adam est complètement
ignorant de la vie en général et ce
comporte n'importe comment OK dans les
comics on retrouve ça aussi peu de temps
après sa sortie du cocon check dans le
MCU le maître de l'évolution a créé Adam
et on a fait une sorte d'élus c'est une
référence au moment où Herbert recueille
Adam Warlock dans les comics pour le
baptiser et l'améliorer check vous voyez
le fonctionnement en faisant ça il y a
clairement moyen de voir ce qui a déjà
été adapté ce qui ne le pourra plus
évidemment et ce qui pourra l'être pour
continuer si l'on s'intéresse plus en
détail à la vie d'Adam Warlock dans les
comics je vous conseille d'ailleurs ma
vidéo dédiée aux personnages pour en
savoir plus mais il y a deux éléments
très marquants dans l'épopée d'Adam
Warlock qu'il faut souligner
[Musique]
l'une des choses fondamentales qui
caractérise le développement de
l'histoire d'Adam c'est l'évolution il
est un être artificiellement créé et qui
s'imprègne constamment de son entourage
et ses aventures pour avancer cependant
pour faciliter cette thématique dans les
comics Adam Warlock s'est vu être
amélioré par le maître de l'évolution
qui lui a conféré la pierre de l'âme sur
son front bon petit point culture à
l'origine la pierre présente sur le
front d'Adam worlock n'est qu'une
émeraude ce sera plus tard qu'elle sera
désignée comme la gemme de l'âme et
encore bien plus tard quel sera définie
comme une pierre d'infinité les
scénaristes ont modifié l'histoire au
fur et à mesure car il n'avait pas prévu
les pierres d'infinité dès le départ la
gemme de l'âme était avant tout une
pierre pour
upgrade les capacités d'Adam Warlock et
du coup quand elle va devenir une gemme
de l'âme cela va complètement redessiner
la manière du personnage car la pierre
de l'âme est en reliée aux âmes
justement Adam Warlock va pouvoir mieux
comprendre ce qu'il entoure il pourra
sonder l'âme des gens comprendre leurs
émotions leur peur et c'est un artefact
qui va beaucoup servir à son
développement pour le MCU forcément les
pierres d'infinité ne sont plus
d'actualité elles servaient de McGuffin
soit l'objet central qui justifie le
scénario est désormais elles ne sont
plus accessibles il y a même eu une
désacralisation des pierres dans la
phase 4 avec notamment la série Loki qui
introduit complètement l'essence de la
saga du multivers donc tout ça c'est
pour bien souligner d'après moi que les
pierres c'est du passé ce qui veut dire
kadam Warlock dans le MCU n'aura pas la
pierre de l'âme après chacun peut voir
midi à sa porte et s'amuser à imaginer
des théories comme quoi nous pourrions
avoir un retour d'une ou des pierres
d'infinité permettant du à Adam de
récupérer celle de l'âme mais je vous
avoue qu'actuellement de mon côté je n'y
crois pas trop donc nouvel élément à
rayer de la liste et en second lieu nous
devons parler de la saga Infinity
guntlet en fait les poupée Infinity war
avec Thanos qui récupère les six pierres
d'infinité et qui par le biais du gant
effectuent le claquement de doigts qui
va faire disparaître 50% de l'existence
c'est une adaptation de cette série de
comics sauf que normalement dans les
comics Infinity outlet nous propose
également une apogée pour Adam Warlock
le véritable héros de l'histoire celui
qui va déjouer Thanos et récupérer le
gant c'est Adam Warlock donc bien
évidemment c'est quelque chose que nous
ne verrons jamais dans le MCU alors
pareil nous pouvons le barrer maintenant
qu'est-ce qu'il nous reste exactement et
bien pour moi il y a deux cas de figure
très probables et franchement il y a de
très très grandes chances pour moi que
cela je vais bien évidemment vous les
présenter et je vais vous expliquer
pourquoi cela devrait arriver tout
d'abord nous pourrions parler de
l'intégration d'Adam Warlock dans
l'équipe des gardiens mais pour moi il
s'agit d'une fausse route en fait
l'essence de l'équipe des gardiens de la
galaxie c'est avant tout apprivoisé
entre guillemets le bon côté de
personnage qui ne le sont pas Queen
était un ravageur aujourd'hui il ne veut
plus tuer personne au contraire Drax
était désigné comme le Destructeur
aujourd'hui il est caractérisé comme un
père les gardiens sont composés de
personnages dépravés voire vicieux et
grâce au travail d'équipe et au vivre
ensemble ils deviennent finalement de
bonnes personnes des héros Adam Warlock
dans l'équipe des gardiens c'est avant
tout un moyen pour lui de grandir
côtoyer des personnes qui vont lui faire
prendre une bonne direction et par
conséquent l'éduquer point
[Musique]
moi là ce dont je veux vraiment vous
parler c'est quel serait les prochaines
grandes lignes scénaristiques de
l'histoire d'Adam Warlock dans le MCU et
en fonction du coup des de l'air actuel
des films premier cas de figure
l'adaptation de la saga du meilleur
si vous préférez le prononcer en latin
nous sommes dans la saga du multivers
Kang est destiné à devenir le prochain
vilain principal de la firme et par
conséquent cela exploite à fond le
concept de voyage dans le temps et en
plus de cela la thématique du multivers
c'est amener le concept de réalité
alternative et donc des variants pour
nos personnages ce sera d'ailleurs le
cœur des prochains films Avengers pour
revenir à la saga du meilleur c'est une
série de comics qui colle parfaitement
avec tout ça en gros make us à l'origine
il s'agit d'un Adam Warlock du futur un
Adam qui on pourrait vulgariser en mode
il a pris un mauvais chemin il est
connaître un femme pervers et corrompu
c'est l'opposé de notre Adam Warlock il
est en quelque sorte le mal qui existe
un intérieur de lui et dans les comics
du coup may Ghost va s'interposer dans
la vie de notre héros pour cADAM
empreinte le même chemin que lui et
deviennent à son tour maigas pour le
futur c'est l'instauration d'une boucle
temporelle une boucle qu'Adam Warlock
réussira finalement à modifier en créant
une nouvelle empêchant la naissance de
ma gueule dans une adaptation pour le
MCU avec la thématique du multivers avec
la thématique du non libre arbitre et du
fait que Kang oriente l'histoire à
toutes les époques pour se hisser en
tant que grand vainqueur nous pourrions
pourquoi pas avoir une réalité
alternative ou Adam Warlock a été
recueilli et guidé par Kang ou un autre
de ses variants et cette route l'aurait
finalement fait devenir make us après
peut-être qu'il s'agit d'un simple
fantasme mais ce qui est vraiment
intéressant là-dedans c'est que vu
qu'Adam Warlock est un être en constante
évolution pour devenir toujours meilleur
et que son pire ennemi du coup bah c'est
lui-même car personne n'est son égal
mais bon ça on va y revenir et bien il
se retrouve très souvent à affronter ma
gueule qui symbolise en gros tout le mal
qu'il a en lui il y a clairement moyen
de faire de cet ennemi un variant dans
le MCU surtout que le grand rival des
comics d'Adam Warlock Thanos et
désormais mort et nous avons tendance à
l'oublier mais vu que les univers
alternatifs naissent à partir des
événements Nexus des moments modifiés de
l'histoire qui n'aurait pas dû
apparaître et bien cela colle
parfaitement un être tierce ou un
événement aurait pu modifier la
trajectoire d'Adam Warlock et cela
donnerait naissance à un univers
alternatif où il deviendra megas
second cas de figure celui que je veux
voir absolument c'est l'avènement du
côté prophétique d'Adam Warlock je vous
disais tout à l'heure que personne
n'était légal de ce héros et bien c'est
vrai la thématique phare du personnage
son essence même je dirais c'est qu'il
est un être destiné à devenir parfait
Adam Warlock étant à l'origine un être
artificiel puissant et déjà à l'âge
adulte il est dépourvu de la faiblesse
des hommes et de leurs émotions et ça
cela intéresse les êtres cosmiques vous
en avez déjà très certainement entendu
parler mais Adam Warlock est désigné
dans les comics comme le champion de la
vie en fait l'entité qui symbolise la
mort à désigner Thanos comme son
champion et pour équilibrer l'univers
les êtres cosmiques ont dû choisir
quelqu'un pour tenir tête au Titan et
c'est Adam Warlock qui a été désigné et
tout ça en plus de son épopée sur la
contre terre et bien cela appuie son
côté prophétique un côté prophétique qui
a été taquiné dans les gardiens de la
galaxie 3 avec les références bibliques
Adam Warlock est la seule entité de
l'univers Marvel a possédé un lien
particulier avec les dieux les êtres
cosmiques c'est pourquoi il est désigné
comme une sorte de Messi par exemple
dans Infinity guntlet qui est l'histoire
d'origine d'Infinity war Adam Warlock en
tant qu'opposition naturelle et
ultime de Thanos va réunir derrière lui
la totalité des Avengers mais pas
seulement il va aussi aller à la
rencontre des êtres cosmiques et les
rallier derrière lui pour défaire le
Titan il est le véritable lien entre les
mortels et les divinités il a été choisi
par ces derniers et 16 qui le rend
vraiment unique dans le MCU les êtres
cosmiques sont ramenés petit à petit et
il est clair que nous allons en voir
d'autres au fur et à mesure que
l'histoire avance par conséquent la
prochaine grande étape de l'histoire
d'Adam Warlock dans les films c'est
qu'il se retrouve au bout d'un moment en
contact avec ses êtres ces mêmes je
dirais un moyen pour les scénaristes de
les introduire à partir de là nous
pouvons compter seulement sur notre
imagination car avec ce procédé et bien
tout est possible pour Adam Warlock mais
par rapport aux futurs productions à
venir et bien je vous avoue que j'ai
déjà un peu réfléchi à la question déjà
je me suis demandé si Adam Warlock ne
pouvait pas devenir le héros de Galactus
car on sait que ce dernier va apparaître
très certainement dans la prochaine
phase mais au vu de la popularité du
surfeur d'argent et les thématiques
d'Adam Warlock ainsi que ses valeurs je
ne pense pas que cela arrivera d'un
autre côté je me dis qu'il y a moyen
aussi de relier le personnage avec les
éternels ce sont des héros qui
s'intéressent avant tout à l'aspect
cosmique de Marvel donc tout comme Adam
Warlock chez les éternels il y a aussi
un côté très biblique et en plus de cela
les Célestes pourraient être catégorisés
comme des êtres cosmiques imaginez un
seul instant kadam Warlock se rapproche
des éternels pour confronter les
Célestes je ne pense pas néanmoins qu'il
rejoindraient à Richelle par exemple car
ce serait contraire à ces valeurs
puisqu'à H&M et les Célestes même s'ils
apportent la vie ils en enlèvent
énormément et je pense qu'ils vont quand
même développer un minimum ce côté
Sauveur champion de la vie chez Adam
worlock surtout en plus qu'il a rejoint
les gardiens qui vont lui faire prendre
la bonne direction mais bref en réalité
mon fantasme
ultime concernant Adam worlog dans le
MCU ce serait une liaison avec le
tribunal vivant l'un des faits les plus
incroyables concernant Adam Warlock dans
les comics c'est que dans un autre
univers il va devenir le tribunal vivant
le tribunal vivant pour celles et ceux
qui ne le connaissent pas c'est en gros
le second Dieu ultime de l'univers
Marvel il n'en existe qu'un seul dans
tout le multivers et ce dernier veille à
ce que ce dernier ne s'effondre pas et
reste équilibré dans le sens où il peut
y avoir des personnages qui accumulent
beaucoup trop de puissance par rapport
aux autres univers au point de menacer
du coup le multivers en lui-même en fait
c'est là que ces passionnant le tribunal
vivant dans les comics est tué juste
avant les événements de Secret Wars
Secret Wars qui va aboutir sur une
guerre multiverselle et donc la fin du
multivers je pense que vous voyez où je
veux en venir mais Secret Wars et le
film final de la phase 6 et au vu de ce
qui va arriver le tribunal vivant devra
obligatoirement apparaître surtout que
vu les nombreuses références faites à
cette entité dans les films voilà on
sait qu'il existe et petite précision
mais après les événements de Secret Wars
dans les comics et le relancement du
multivers c'est un Adam Warlock
alternatif très proche de celui de la
terre 616 qui va devenir du coup le
nouveau tribunal vivant donc voilà pour
moi il nous faut une référence à tout ça
je serai scénariste chez Marvel je
proposerai l'idée qu'adames se ferait
approcher par le tribunal vivant pour
devenir en quelque sorte son subordonnés
dont l'univers 616 un moyen qui
permettrait à Adam Warlock d'avoir une
mission divine comme dans les comics
avec le champion de la vie un lien
également avec la saga du multivers mais
aussi une intégration pour le tribunal
vivant qui devra obligatoirement
intervenir pendant la destruction des
univers à cause de Secret Wars et enfin
vu que comme je vous ai dit dans les
comics Adam Warlock prend la place du
précédent tribunal vivant et bien tout
ça ce serait une gigabelle référence à
l'univers des comics
mais voilà nous n'avons aucune
information aucune véritable direction
pour le personnage nous sommes donc
libres de théoriser comme on le veut
mais pour moi il faut absolument que
Marvel studio développe le côté
prophétique d'Adam Warlock pour le futur
du MCU et donc la liaison qu'il possède
avec les dieux cosmiques ce qui
permettra d'ailleurs de les introduire
pour les films mais à vous de me dire ce
que vous en pensez la création de ma
gueule ce parkang les diocosmiques autre
chose qu'est-ce qui vous hype le plus
comment vous voyez l'avenir d'Adam
worlock dans les films Marvel dites moi
tout ça en commentaire et si la vidéo
vous a plu n'oubliez pas également le
petit pouce bleu et surtout à vous
abonner pour montrer votre soutien
j'espère en tout cas vraiment que Marvel
va nous proposer quelque chose de
vraiment stylé pour Adam Warlock car au
vu du film des gardiens et des scènes
Paul génériques le personnage va devenir
une entité récurrente des films donc
j'ai vraiment pas envie qu'il le loupe
je vous avoue mais en tout cas je reste
très curieux des choix qu'ils vont faire
sur ce on se retrouve prochainement pour
de nouvelles vidéos en attendant
n'hésitez pas à voir les autres et puis
celles sur Adam Warlock précisément dans
les comics que le line hard soit avec
vous c’était argorock allez ciao tout le
monde
[Musique]